we just got samsung's brand new s22  ultra what we're gonna find out in this  video is if it can take down the iphone  13 pro max i have an hdr youtube video  open right here with the same settings  on both this is really weird because the  iphone even though it only goes up to  1200 instead of 1750 it looks generally  brighter  [Music]  both single core and multi-core is 38  faster on the iphone now i turned on the  extreme stress test and the point of  this is to see if we get any display  dimming on either of these phones and i  am noticing that the samsung has also  dimmed down not quite to the same level  as the iphone but it's definitely dim  and in terms of the fps the iphone is  still beating it out in basically every  scene the iphone actually got 2 hours  and 19 minutes more screen on time than  the s22 ultra the iphone is still the  battery life king